[Musik]
nachrichten des tages heute messbar
hahlweg
guten abend schön dass sie dabei sind
wir auch norbert lehmann für den sport
talk show guten abend familie die
regierung rüstet sich für gas mangel
schutzschirm für angeschlagene
gasversorger die bundesregierung will im
notfall eingreifen für verbraucher
könnte das teuer werden
kritische lage in krankenhäusern immer
mehr personal meldet sich krank
stationen müssen zeitweise geschlossen
werden
und deutsches duell in wimbledon tatiana
maria schlägt jule niemeyer und steht
auf dem heiligen rasen im halbfinale
die bundesregierung bereitet sich darauf
vor dass in wenigen tagen möglicherweise
gar kein gas mehr aus russland kommt
damit es trotzdem über den winter reicht
beschloss das kabinett heute änderungen
am energie sicherungs gesetz im notfall
kann der staat damit auch die größten
energieversorger leichter retten
allerdings werden auch privathaushalte
wohl deutlich mehr bezahlen müssen
andreas huppert hat details
noch fließt russisches gas durch die
unterirdischen röhren von nord stream
einst nach deutschland
in gut einer woche ist damit erstmal
schluss die pipeline muss gewartet
werden wie jedes jahr im sommer um die
zehn tage dauert das diesmal ist
fraglich ob die russen den hahn
überhaupt wieder aufmachen im moment
sind wir im wesentlichen damit
beschäftigt dass wir die gasspeicher
füllen wir brauchen die gasspeicher für
den winter aber wenn die lieferungen auf
null prozent gehen dann wird die
situation schwierig mit dem ukraine
krieges deutlich geworden wie abhängig
deutschland am gas tropft der russen
hängt die bundesregierung will weg von
putins gas doch ersatz ist viel teurer
deshalb hat der wirtschaftsminister
instrumente entwickelt in das alte
energie sicherheitsgesetz zu
aktualisieren diese beiden instrumente
sind
scharfe schwerter besondere instrumente
die wir jetzt uns geben die wir aber
noch nicht nutzen wollen und die wir nur
mit grosser mit großem bedacht anwenden
würden ein instrument die
preisanpassungsklausel damit kann die
bundesregierung die höheren gasimport
kosten auf alle kunden verteilen auch
auf die die eigentlich wirklich einen
niedrigeren preis zahlen müssten die
nächsten jahre werden wir mit höheren
energiekosten rechnen müssen ein
weiteres instrument der schutzschirm für
gas importeure geraten diese wegen der
extremen einkaufspreise in finanzielle
schieflage kann der staat stützend
eingreifen wenn die unternehmen jetzt
das gas nachkaufen müssen zum auf dem
spot-markt zu denen jetzt ja immens
hohen preisen gibt es ein - das ist das
problem dieses - können unternehmen eine
zeit lang aushalten aber sicherlich
nicht grenzenlos und deswegen muss man
ein bisschen schauen wie sich die
situation entwickelt noch sind die
scharfen schwerter des energie
sicherungs gesetzes nicht in kraft die
nächsten wochen entscheiden ob die
bundesregierung wirklich auf alle
szenarien in sachen gasimporte
vorbereitet ist
ökostrom würde helfen die abhängigkeit
zu senken und das klima zu schützen die
regierung will den anteil am strom aus
wind und sonne massiv ausbauen das war
klar um das wie gab es noch streit jetzt
hat sich die ampel koalition auf eine
ganze reihe von maßnahmen geeinigt hat
tritt ja wiedemeier hat mehr
es geht voran mit dem ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien wenn auch zu
langsam knapp die hälfte des
stromverbrauchs 6 prozent mehr als im
vorjahr konnte im ersten halbjahr vor
allem durch windenergie und photovoltaik
anlagen gedeckt werden bis zum ende
dieses jahrzehnts sollen es 80 prozent
seien alle bundesländer müssen dann zwei
prozent ihrer fläche für
windkraftanlagen zur verfügung stellen
abstandsregeln die wind ausbau
verhindern und damit dazu führen dass
ein bundesland diesen anteil für den
bund nicht zur verfügung stellt wird es
dann nicht mehr geben können wir haben
auch sanktionen festgelegt und das ist
uns sehr wichtig die bundesländer dürfen
sich nicht mehr aus der verantwortung
stehlen und sagen bei uns geht das nicht
das verbindliche ziel der treibhausgas
neutralität des energiesektors bis 20 35
wurde von der fdp gestrichen für sie
wichtig dass die ökostromumlage ausläuft
wir werden im rahmen dieser reform des
erneuerbaren energien gesetzes
sicherstellen dass wir das eeg auch
enden lassen das ist ein enddatum für
diesen plan wirtschaftlicheren ansatz
gibt
hinzu kommt genehmigungsverfahren sollen
beschleunigt arten und naturschutz
gesetze geändert werden für die
opposition nicht genug und auf der
anderen seite fallen andere regenerative
energien hinten runter wie zb die
wasserkraft die biomasse die geothermie
und das ist mit sicherheit in sich nicht
schlüssig
trotz der kritik am donnerstag wird der
bundestag wohl insgesamt sieben
energiegesetze verabschieden
corona quarantäne oder einfach nur ein
schnupfen der krankenstand in den
kliniken ist derzeit enorm hoch einige
krankenhäuser mussten bereits
abteilungen schließen laut der letzten
schätzung des robert koch-instituts
litten ende juni 4,5 millionen menschen
unter akuten atemwegsbeschwerden viele
davon infiziert mit corona die zahlen
sind deutlich höher als sonst um diese
jahreszeit heike kruse und jan frederik
fischer
notaufnahme uniklinik schleswig holstein
bei krankenpfleger tiefs patrick
springer und seinen kollegen herrscht
ausnahmezustand denn am gesamten
klinikum vielen 400 mitarbeiter die
meisten von ihnen sind wegen einer krone
infektion in quarantäne es ist ein
arbeiten am limit mitten im dritten
kurve ja das war ein unglaublich viele
kollegen aus wir haben sehr sehr viele
kollegen einspringen müssen
die versorgung in kiel ist desolat dass
man ganz ehrlich sagen warum die
infektionszahlen ausgerechnet im hohen
norden so die höhe schießen ist unklar
doch es ist urlaubszeit und viele
menschen besuchen großveranstaltungen so
strömten rund drei millionen besucher
bis ende juni zur kieler woche die
angespannte lage kein einzelfall erklärt
die deutsche krankenhausgesellschaft im
ganzen land müssten einzelne stationen
schließen besorgnis dass wir die
versorgung wie wir sie gewohnt sind
nicht mehr in dem maße sicherstellen
können das ist eine bittere erkenntnis
nach zwei jahren an demi und ein
wirklich schweres versäumnis der politik
auch am klinikum stuttgart hinterlässt
das virus seine spuren allein hierauf
der schlaganfallstation haben sich von
40 mitarbeitern fünf krank gemeldet die
patientenversorgung ist noch nicht
gefährdet aber schon jetzt brauche es
grosse flexibilität für dieses
anspruchsvolle sind die leider gewohnt
jetzt die letzten jahre sind ja auch
menschen mit familien kindern und so
weiter also da muss man gleich doppelt
jonglieren doch wie lange das gut geht
ist fraglich und das obwohl der chor
ohne herbst noch gar nicht begonnen hat
jahrzehntelang waren schweden und
finnland neutral doch wegen des
russischen angriffs auf die ukraine
wollen beide in die nato heute ging es
einen schritt weiter in brüssel
unterzeichneten die botschafter des
nordatlantischen verteidigungsbündnisses
die beitritts protokolle nun müssen die
parlamente aller 30 mitglieder noch
zustimmen das könnte bis zu acht monate
dauern im schweizerischen lugano sind
erste weichen gestellt worden für den
wiederaufbau der vom krieg zerstörten
ukraine mehr als 40 staaten und
organisationen verpflichteten sich zur
hilfe und formulierten mehrere
grundprinzipien eines davon der
wiederaufbau soll digital verwaltet
werden um korruption vorzubeugen
währenddessen gehen die kämpfe im land
weiter nach der vollständigen einnahme
der region lohans nehmen russische
truppen zunehmend donetsk ins visier
nach einschätzung der vereinten nationen
haben sowohl russische als auch
ukrainische truppen gegen das
völkerrecht verstoßen un
menschenrechtskommissarin
bachelet wird beiden kriegsparteien vor
menschen als schutzschilde zu
missbrauchen
kriegsgefangene seien gefoltert und
misshandelt worden auch seien fälle
sexualisierter gewalt dokumentiert
bereits vor fast vier monaten hatte das
zdf ein mutmaßliches kriegsverbrechen
durch russische soldaten aufgedeckt es
ging um die ermordung eines wehrlosen
elternpaars nike nun fanden unsere
reporter heraus es gab wohl weitere
angriffe auf fliehende zivilisten am
gänze und christian rohde berichten
tödliche schüsse auf zivilisten
mutmaßliche kriegsverbrechen russischer
truppen auf der schütte moskau autobahn
westlich von kiew jetzt bestätigt die
ukrainische staatsanwaltschaft die zdf
recherchen
wir haben die leichen von maximal wenk
und xenia identifiziert insgesamt haben
die russischen angreifer an der autobahn
57 fahrzeuge beschossen
36 tote körper wurden gefunden darunter
sind kinder
wir sind noch einmal am tatort und
finden spuren
hier liegen überall patronenhülsen von
schweren waffen und zwar ist dass der
kopf von einer equipment liste also hier
steht welches equipment man an die
soldaten ausgereicht hat im formular
kopf der zahlencode der einheit 4 6 10 8
die stammt aus bous razzien mehr als
6000 kilometer von der ukraine entfernt
sie gehört zur fünften panzerbrigade in
ulan oder der hauptstadt von razzien in
den verlassenen stellungen die armbinde
eines offiziers auf der innenseite namen
von rekruten
offenbar quoten hier entlang der straße
junger männer eingesetzt die
sich in der ausbildung befanden bei der
armee also rekruten verantwortung für
die soldaten trägt laut unterlagen die
wir vor ort gefunden haben kommandeur
andré wigdorovits control russische
truppen haben die schütte minister
autobahn zur straße des todes gemacht
bisher musste sich keiner der täter
verantworten
über ihre recherchen und enthüllungen
haben unsere reporter eine dokumentation
gemacht zu sehen jeder zeit in der zdf
mediathek
und über den russischen vormarsch in der
ukraine spricht zdf heute live um 19 uhr
30 mit einem militärexperten sie können
dabei sein in der zdf- heute- app und
auf unseren social media kanälen
in einem vorort von chicago hatte ein
mann gestern während der parade zum
unabhängigkeitstag offenbar wahllos in
die menge geschossen einige stunden
danach konnte der mutmaßliche schütze
nach kurzer verfolgungsjagd festgenommen
werden ermittler suchen nun nach dem
motiv des 21-jährigen bei der bluttat
waren sechs menschen getötet und etwa 25
verletzt worden
der norden italiens leidet immer noch
unter hohen temperaturen und extremer
dürre die regierung hat für fünf
regionen den notstand ausgerufen
am längsten fluss italiens dem po sind
die wasserstände teilweise so niedrig
wie seit 70 jahren nicht mehr in dem
land wirtschaftlich wichtigen gebiet
vertrocknen auf den feldern die pflanzen
einige städte haben wasser bereits
rationiert
auch das lawinenunglück vorgestern ist
nach ansicht vieler experten eine folge
der ungewöhnlichen wärme mindestens
sieben bergsteiger waren dabei in den
tod gerissen worden der unglücksort
liegt in den norditalienischen dolomiten
amberg marmolada war ein riesiger
eisblock vom gletscher abgebrochen
annette hilsenbeck über die gefährliche
suche nach noch fünf vermissten
mit hubschraubern und mit
spezialausrüstung versuchen die retter
die signale der handys von vermissten zu
orten aus der luft nachdem gestern
schlechtes wetter ihre suche
unterbrochen hatte
dies ermöglicht uns telefon signale zu
orten und dann die telefonnummer die zu
der sim karte des handys gehört zu
ermitteln la liga del toro rosso château
la scala telefonica drohnen im einsatz
haben kleidungsstücke geortet die wohl
vermissten gehören doch die retter
dürfen die bergflanke zur zeit nicht
betreten ein weiterer block könnte am
gletscher abstürzen experten
installieren daher jetzt radargeräte zur
überwachung
damit wir und die retter wissen was über
uns passiert
anhand wissenschaftlicher daten zum
beispiel brüche im reis denn wir
erwarten dass es sich bewegt
die särge der opfer sind im eisstadion
von canazei aufgebaut noch sind nicht
alle identifiziert andreas bari hat
seinen bruder verloren der hatte ihm
noch ein handy foto aus den bergen
gesendet 20 minuten bevor die lawine kam
dieses foto zeigt mein bruder war
lachend ein fantastischer mensch
er ist gestorben
die retter suchen weiter nach den
letzten fünf vermissten es wird noch
wochen dauern bis es gewissheit gibt bis
alle opfer geborgen sind
frankfurts oberbürgermeister feldmann
hat seinen rückzug angekündigt für
januar kommenden jahres damit wolle er
der stadt ein quälendes und teures
abwahlverfahren ersparen der
spd-politiker ist wegen
korruptionsverdacht angeklagt ein
vorwurf er habe seiner frau einen
übertariflich bezahlten job verschafft
in würde und vertrauter atmosphäre
sterben das wollen die meisten von uns
in pflegeheimen ist das mitunter unnötig
schwer weil die menschen noch zwischen
heim und krankenhaus hin und her
geschoben werden das passiert viel zu
häufig und es wäre vermeidbar ergab
jetzt der pflege report der krankenkasse
aok
franziska wunderlich
erika burkart lebt im freiberger
seniorenheim wie sie hier lebt auch in
den letzten stunden möchte sie selbst
bestimmen ich will hier im heim mal die
letzten stunden verbringen würde mich
sehr freuen wenn ich mal schönes ende
hätte und dass mir mal jemand der hand
hält ein wunsch den sie mit vielen teilt
doch die wirklichkeit sieht oft anders
aus das legt auch der aok pflegereport
nah in dem dazu mehr als 500 pflege
mitarbeitende befragt wurden jeder
fünfte befragte sagt dass er monatlich
oder häufiger beobachtet dass eben
krankenhauseinweisungen am lebensende
stattfinden obwohl diese nicht im sinne
des kunden sind
lückenhafte patientenverfügungen
überforderte angehörige überlastetes
pflegepersonal
laut report wäre jede dritte krankenhaus
verlegung in den letzten lebenswochen
vermeidbar gewesen
es braucht personelle ressourcen dazu es
braucht aber auch eine gute
zusammenarbeit zwischen den professionen
das heißt zwischen den mitarbeiterinnen
und mitarbeitern in der
pflegeeinrichtung mit den hausärztinnen
hausärzte mit den krankenhäusern und mit
dem rettungsdienst und da ist
erforderlich dass da wirklich auch eine
verbesserte kommunikation passiert in
freiberg versuchen sie genau außerdem
schreiben darauf geschulte berater mit
den bewohnern ihrer letzten wünsche fest
und sind damit eher die ausnahme denn
klar ist auch wer berät kann nicht
pflegen und fehlt auf der station
jetzt zum sport aufregender tag für alle
tennisfans norbert zwei deutsche frauen
im viertelfinale von wimbledon
aber leider konnte ja nur eine gewinnen
wir aber wirklich es hätten beide
verdient weiterzukommen rainer maria 34
und julia niemeyer 22 die zeigten tennis
vom allerfeinsten ein packendes duell
auf augenhöhe
dass die routiniertere von den beiden
knapp mit 2 1 sätzen gewannen
noch kann sie es nicht fassen tatiana
maria gewinnt das deutsch-deutsche
viertelfinale gegen julia niemeyer die
zweifache mutter setzt sich gegen die
zwölf jahre jüngere dortmunderin mit den
nötigen biss und willen durch nach
nervösem auftakt bei dem maria den
wellen geradezu hinterherlaufen muss
findet sie im verlauf immer besser ins
match im zweiten durchgang erkämpft sie
den satzausgleich serve-and-volley
exakte stopps aber auch eine gute
vorhand ihr rezept für den sieg
vielleicht was meine erfahrung dass
keine ahnung aber ich meine ich habe
gekämpft bis zum ende und bin
überglücklich dass das gewinnen konnte
nach zwei stunden und 18 minuten
verwandelt sie den ersten matchball zum
4 6 6 2 und 7 5 und spielt am donnerstag
um den einzug ins endspiel
ja und tatjana maria ist jetzt die
letzte deutsche im turnier nachdem das
doppel credit suisse danach im
viertelfinale ausgeschieden ist ja von
den deutschen tennisspielern zu den
deutschen fußball-frauen in london die
bereiten sich dort auf ihr erstes wm
gruppenspiel am freitag gegen dänemark
vor zu sehen live bei uns im zdf das
trainergespann voss tecklenburg und
carlson ging heute ganz auf nummer
sicher sara däbritz wurde geschont ein
ausfall der erfahrenen mittelfeld
akteure soll unbedingt vermieden werden
er hatte leichte muskuläre probleme wir
wollten wir jetzt kein risiko eingehen
das turnier steht bevor also ich glaube
wenn wir jetzt schon finalspiele hätten
dann hätten wir sie auch einsetzen
können so musste sara däbritz heute ganz
ohne ball auskommen ihre mitspielerinnen
hatten das sicher mehr spaß beim
training
baut van aart hat die vierte etappe der
tour de france gewonnen und seine
führung in der gesamtwertung ausgebaut
der belgier siegte nach 171 5 kilometer
von dünkirchen nach calais im alleingang
vor seinem landsmann jasper philippsen
und dem franzosen christophe legout
und morgen die erste etappe mit
kopfsteinpflaster durchaus chancen für
die deutschen fahrer auf einen
etappensieg werden wir sehen vielen dank
überwiegend trocken sieht es beim wetter
aus mehr dazu hat gleich aus dem verlies
das heute journal mit christian sievers
um viertel vor zehn und wir sind morgen
wieder daraufhin sehen würde machen sie
sich einen schönen abend auch wieder
sehen
[Musik]
schon guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter das umfangreiche
hoch über dem atlantik bleibt immer noch
das azorenhoch ansonsten bekommen wir es
hier mit diesem tief zu tun und das
schiebt etwas regen vor allem in den
norden zum beispiel richtung alpen da
ist es größtenteils trocken kein
nennenswerter regen weiterhin in sicht
schauen wir in die nacht etwas regen
ganz im norden sonst klart es vor allem
nach süden hin auf und die temperaturen
gehen zurück auf 8 grad im westen und 14
grad in den östlichen landesteilen und
morgen im tagesverlauf meist viel
sonnenschein nach norden hin mehr wolken
dann kommen allerdings von norden her
mit dieser warmfront einige schauer bis
etwa richtung norddeutsche tiefebene und
das kann auch kurz mal kräftiger regnen
bei temperaturen von 25 grad im süden
deutschlands das sind die höchstwerte
des morgigen tages und 18 grad richtung
schleswig holstein es ist also nicht
mehr ganz so warm wie zuletzt schauen
auf die nächsten tage am donnerstag
kommt das tief weiter voran es gibt
schauer und gewitter es kann auch mal
kräftig regnen vorübergehend werte bis
25 grad und danach wird es wieder
trockener damit ein schöner abend